I will list 15 words in your ears
Then, I want you to write as much as you can.
Ready to listen? Okay
Acid
Nice
Dessert
honey
sugar
Soda
Over
chocolate
good
heart
Taste
Cakes
age
Pie
Candy Pie
Stop this section now and without words you can not cheat
Even if you get confused, close your eyes and think, you will often bring more of them.
Are you ready to show your work?
Well, maybe some of you picked up a few of the words you finally listed like:
age
Pie
And pancake candy
But do you remember a word?
Sweet?
Be honest, most of you now suddenly began to write the word "sweet" although they were not listed at all.
This is what we call
Counterfeit Memory.
It is a psychological phenomenon in which the person invokes things that have not happened.
For example, how many people remember well that the monopolist wears glasses with one lens?
But he never had a single glasses.
Or who remembers the sentence in Star Wars "Luke, I am Your Father"
While he did not say "neither, I am your father"
Or who remembers the evil witch saying "My mirror, my mirror on the wall ..."
She said, "My mirror on the wall ...
Memories are initially formed in the hippocampus part of the brain, one of the only members to build completely new neurons
This information is maintained by neurotransmitters and the establishment of neural links.
Sometimes, however, they focus on the big details of your experience
You may remember time, place and people but you do not have to remember the color of their hats.
However, your memories are not complete.
If new information overlaps during the period between your living and an event,
And your attempt to restore it.
For example, if someone tells you something different from what happened
This may change but may replace your memory entirely.
Then these memories gradually migrate away towards the cerebral cortex until they become your real memories.
Whenever you think about an event, or fail to invoke it
This new reality is further entrenched.
This simple effect may have somewhat incredible consequences
Such as the case of eyewitnesses in crimes, or incidents when they conjure false details
Indeed, a study has come to the conclusion that when a car accident is presented to people
Then the question of two teams, how fast the two cars when colliding with each other?
Or, how fast were the cars when they smashed each other?
The answer to those who heard the word "smash" often tells higher speeds
It is the same word that often made them say they saw the glass debris in the accident, although there was no glass at all
In a similar study, a car was shown heading towards the stop signal causing an accident
However, when asked if the reference to road priority is indicated, many witnesses will confirm that it was indeed the priority of the road.
This has sometimes reduced the testimony of witnesses, unless they are reinforced and confirmed.
Finally, some studies have established false childhood memories in the minds of some test specimens
The researchers gave the samples four short stories describing childhood events they had experienced
But without the knowledge of the samples, the stories included a false account of their loss of commercial status in their childhood
Thus, 25% of the samples said they remembered the fake incident
Do you think your memory is better?
So, how did this section begin?
I mean, in addition to our logo, which we present at the beginning of each section we present
Can you remember what happened next?
Except that we did not display the logo at the beginning of the section.
If you think we did, your memory has a false memory.
Make sure you check out our new sections by clicking on the screen or visiting the link provided in the description.
Participate in the channel, for more scientific sections every week every Thursday. Translate: Team translated @Autrjim